vamos ahora con nuestra segunda Crónica
de economía y ya está lista de nuevo en
el estudio Daniela hablando en una Hola
de nuevo Daniela Hola Rosa vamos con una
buena noticia la ocde mejora sus
perspectivas a nivel mundial Pues de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económicos También conocido
como el club de países ricos cree que la
economía mundial va a crecer 2,7% este
año 5 décimas más de lo que esperaba en
noviembre pasado
los riesgos siguen inclinados a la baja
tenemos desafíos políticos
significativos por delante está la
incertidumbre causada por el impacto
global de la continua guerra de Rusia
contra Ucrania y también otras tensiones
geopolíticas
este invierno se evitó la escasez de gas
en Europa y no ocurrieron interrupciones
importantes en los mercados petroleros
pero debemos permanecer atentos ya que
algunas de las condiciones favorables
que ayudaron a reducir la demanda de
energía el año pasado como un invierno
suave en Europa pueden no repetirse este
año
todos ahora le invito a que demos un
repaso rápidamente por América Latina
pues se destaca una mejora para Chile
México y Brasil mientras que para Perú
Colombia y Argentina la proyección es
más baja hoy que hace 7 meses en el caso
de este último de Argentina se prevé que
los estrictos controles de capitales y
también incertidumbre política antes de
las elecciones presidenciales de octubre
próximo van a frenar la inversión y el
consumo este año también se espera que
la inflación se mantenga sobre el 100%
anual al menos en el corto plazo Daniela
y ahora le propongo que cambiemos de
tema y vayamos con una peculiar
situación que se da en la ciudad de
Nueva York y es que las autoridades
denuncian a dos gigantes de la industria
Automotriz asiáticos por la fabricación
de sus automóviles no demasiado seguros
no Sí Rosa pues atención a la razón
porque la demanda que pesa sobre Hyundai
motor y Kia corp los acusa a esos
fabricantes surcoreanos de negligencia y
de crear una molestia pública al vender
vehículos que son demasiado fáciles de
robar en la acción legal presentada en
la corte Federal de Manhattan las
autoridades locales los culpan de no
instalar dispositivos antirrobos
llamados inmovilizadores en la mayoría
de sus automóviles entre 2011 y y esto
los convierte según la ciudad en Casos
prácticamente únicos entre los
fabricantes de automóviles también
agrega que esto ha abierto las puertas
al robo de vehículos a la delincuencia y
a la conducción imprudente bueno Daniela
Esta es la retórica de las autoridades
pero le pregunto qué dicen las cifras al
respecto pues las cifras aparecen
demostrar esta hipótesis porque la
ciudad dice que el número de Hyundai si
de Kia robados se duplicó en el año
pasado segundo seguido de una explosión
de robos en los primeros cuatro meses de
2023 en cambio los robos de vehículos
BMW o Ford Honda Mercedes Nissan y
Toyota han disminuido pero la ciudad más
poblada de Estados Unidos no es la única
hay otras que también han demandado a
estas dos marcas por los robos Baltimore
Cleveland Milwaukee y San Diego siaron
también entre otras Daniela y pasemos a
China porque hoy ha revelado su
situación económica bastante
decepcionante algo que interesa pues a
la economía mundial Claro que sí sus
exportaciones e importaciones cayeron
drásticamente en mayo y eso genera dudas
sobre la frágil recuperación económica
al ser China la segunda economía más
grande del mundo y el mayor consumidor
de gran parte de los insumos que produce
el planeta muchos de ellos acá en
América Latina y es que la economía del
mundo se ha venido desacelerando por el
aumento de las tasas de interés la
inflación que también está reduciendo la
demanda sobre todo en Estados Unidos y
en Europa ahora en el caso de china en
particular las exportaciones cayeron
7,5% interanual en mayo según la oficina
de aduanas mucho más que la caída
prevista del 0,4% su mayor descenso
desde enero y las importaciones se
contrajeron
4,5%. estas estadísticas muestran como
después de un fuerte repunte del
comercio exterior en 2021 los años
siguientes si han venido en caída como
lo veíamos en el gráfico interesante
Daniela y que otras cifras tienen para
nosotros con qué indicadores cerramos
hay quietud en Estados Unidos los
inversionistas se abstienen de hacer
grandes apuestas antes de que se revelen
nuevos datos de inflación Próximamente y
de la reunión de política monetaria de
la reserva Federal prevista para la
próxima semana en Europa las bolsas
operan mixtas se conoció que Alemania
arrojó una producción industrial más
baja de lo esperado en abril
oscureciendo las perspectivas de la
economía más grande de la zona Euro en
Reino Unido también se conoció que
alrededor de 2000 oficiales de seguridad
en el aeropuerto de egistro anunciaron
una huelga por 31 días todo esto a
partir del 24 de junio por los bajos
salarios ahora veamos en Asia los datos
débiles de China no afectaron los
principales índices de ese país al menos
el handseng creció casi un 1% en la
jornada Daniela pues muchísimas gracias
por este repaso económico un día más
mañana nada más con más directo América
aquí nos vemos más y Les traigo más
noticias económicas